PARENTS WERE ON THE SHOW THE
OTHER NIGHT?
NOW, TODAY, I HAD THE HONOR
OF INTERVIEWING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WHO IS FIGHTING HIS
HARDEST TO SECURE THESE
BORDERS.
AND HE WAS DOWN HERE AS
WELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Sean: MR. PRESIDENT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Sean: RIO GRANDE BEHIND
US.
THESE ARE THE GUYS ON THE
FRONT LINE.
YOU ARE GIVING THEM
ENCOURAGING MESSAGES.
RIGHT BEHIND THEM IS
500 POUNDS OF DRUGS THAT
THEY HAVE CAPTURED FROM THIS
RIVER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY ARE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE.
WE HAVE JUST SPENT SOME TIME
TOGETHER AND WE HAD A WHOLE
GROUP AT A MEETING THAT WE
ALSO HAD THAT WAS JUST
COVERED ON YOUR NETWORK AND
OTHER NETWORKS.
AND IT'S INCREDIBLE THE JOB
THEY DO.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THEY HAVE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF DRUGS THAT THEY
JUST CAPTURED RIGHT BEHIND
US.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
IF WE HAD A STEEL BARRIER,
CONCRETE BARRIER, WE
WOULDN'T HAVE THE PROBLEM.
>> Sean: I HAVE SOME SHOTS
THAT WE WILL SHOW IN THIS.
PEOPLE CAN WALK ACROSS THE
RIVER AND TAKE THEM ABOUT,
WHAT, A MINUTE AND A HALF,
TWO MINUTES?
>> THAT'S SO.
>> Sean: THERE IS NO
BARRIER.
ALL THOSE DRUGS GET IN IF
THESE GUYS CAN'T CARRY EVERY
INCH OF, YOU KNOW, THE
2,000 MILES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY HAVE EASY ACCESS INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
WE BUILT A LOT OF WALL.
WE HAVE RENOVATED TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WALL WITH MONEY WE
HAVE ALREADY GOTTEN.
AND WE ARE CONTINUING THAT.
BUT NOW WE JUST REALLY WANT
TO GET IT GOING AND FINISH
IT UP.
WE WILL BUILD THE NEW WALL.
AND IT'S COMMON SENSE.
IT REALLY IS WHEN YOU THINK
OF IT, WHETHER YOU ARE IN TO
THE WORLD OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
LIKE THESE INCREDIBLE FOLKS
BEHIND US THAT UNDERSTAND
THE WALL SO EASILY, I MEAN
IT WOULD MAKE THEIR JOB SO
MUCH BETTER.
AND THEY COULD ALSO GO TO
OTHER AREAS BECAUSE WHERE
YOU HAVE THE WALL YOU DON'T
NEED SO MANY PEOPLE.
WE WOULD PROBABLY PAY FOR
THAT MANY TIMES IN ONE YEAR
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
JUST MANY TIMES.
SO, IT'S NOT A MONEY THING.
IT'S A POLITICAL THING.
THEY LOOK AT THE 2020 RACE
AND NOT FEELING TOO GOOD
ABOUT IT THEY WILL DO
WHATEVER THEY CAN TO WIN.
>> Sean: I HAVE TAPES OF
MAYBE 20 DEMOCRATS THEY ALL
USE THE SAME PHRASE
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
INTERESTINGLY, THEIR BEST
FRIEND IN THE MEDIA ARE ALL
USING THE SAME WORD
"MANUFACTURED CRISIS."
WE HAVE DRUG CARTELS AND
GANGS WE ARE DEALING WITH.
90% OF AMERICA'S HEROIN
CROSSING OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
AND THEN, OF COURSE, WE HAVE
HAD HOMICIDES AND WE HAVE
HAD SEXUAL ASSAULTS.
100,000 VIOLENT ASSAULTS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT
TALKING POINT THE MEDIA AND
THE DEMOCRATS ARE USING THIS
IS MANUFACTURED?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I WATCHED
LAST NIGHT.
I SAW ON YOUR SHOW LAST
NIGHT, ACTUALLY, WHERE YOU
HAD ANCHOR AFTER ANCHOR
USING THE EXACT SAME WORD.
IT'S MANUFACTURED.
MANUFACTURED.
>> Sean: SOUNDS LIKE THEY
WERE IN COLLUSION.
>> A LITTLE COLLUSION.
THAT'S THE REAL COLLUSION,
OKAY?
YOU TAKE A LOOK.
THEY ALL USE THE EXACT SAME
TERM.
LITERALLY THE EXACT SAME TWO
WORDS.
BUT THEY HAD MANUFACTURED.
I SAID WHERE DO THEY COME UP
WITH THAT?
THAT'S A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS.
NO, IT'S A MANUFACTURED
SOUND BITE BECAUSE IT WAS
JUST A SOUND BITE.
BUT EVERY -- VIRTUALLY
EVERY, YOU KNOW, I CALL IT
THE FAKE NEWS.
I'M SURE YOU HAVEN'T HEARD
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT FAKE
NEWS, ACTUALLY.
YOU ARE REAL NEWS.
AND THERE IS SOME OF THAT
AROUND.
UNFORTUNATELY.
THESE ARE GREAT PEOPLE.
THESE ARE PATRIOTIC PEOPLE
THAT DO IT CORRECTLY.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WHEN I HEAR
THAT TERM MANUFACTURED AND
YOU SEE EVERY SINGLE GROUP
USING IT, IT'S VERY SAD.
>> Sean: WE LOSE 300
AMERICANS A WEEK, 90% OF THE
HEROIN COMES INTO THE
COUNTRY.
IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS WE
LOST OFFICER SINGH IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: PIERCE COCHRAN I
HAD HIS PARENTS ON THE SHOW
THIS WEEK.
>> I SAW THAT.
>> Sean: I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU RECOVER AFTER LOSING A
CHILD KILLED BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
I HAVE MET AND INTERVIEWED
SO MANY ANGEL MOMS AND DADS.
>> ME TOO.
>> Sean: ARE THEY GOING TO
SAY THAT TO THEM, THE PEOPLE
THAT LOST THEIR LOVED ONES,
THEIR SONS, THEIR DAUGHTERS,
THEIR PARENTS.
>> SEAN, YOU KNOW, MANY OF
THE PEOPLE THAT AREN'T
GETTING THEIR CHECK, THEY
GET IT THEY WILL GET IT
SOON.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE THEY ARE
WITH US 100 PERCENT.
THEY WANT US TO WIN THIS
BATTLE.
THESE PEOPLE WANT US TO WIN.
EVERYBODY WANTS US TO WIN
THIS BATTLE.
IT'S COMMON SENSE.
DEATH IS POURING THROUGH.
NOT JUST AT THE BORDER.
THEY GET THROUGH THE BORDER.
THEY GO AND FILTER INTO THE
COUNTRY.
YOU WAS MS-13 GANGS IN
DIFFERENT PLACES LIKE LOS
ANGELES AND YOU HAVE GANGS
ALL OVER LONG ISLAND WHICH
WE'RE KNOCKING THE HELL OUT
OF.
THERE SHOULD BE NO REASON
FOR US TO HAVE TO DO.
THIS SHE SHOULDN'T BE
ALLOWED.
IN IF WE HAD THE BARRIER
THEY WOULDN'T BE ALLOWED IN.
>> Sean: EVERYBODY THAT I
HAVE MET AND SPOKEN TO, THEY
ALL SAY TELL THE PRESIDENT
IF YOU SEE HIM HOLD THE
LINE.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> Sean: YOU SAID EARLIER
TODAY THAT IT'S LIKELY THAT
YOU ARE VERY LIKELY GOING TO
DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
HOW SOON WOULD THAT HAPPEN?
>> IF WE DON'T MAKE A DEAL
WITH CONGRESS, MOST LIKELY I
WILL DO THAT I WOULD
ACTUALLY SAY I WOULD.
I CAN'T IMAGINE ANY REASON
WHY NOT BECAUSE I'M ALLOW
YOU HAD TO DO IT.
THE LAW IS 100 PERCENT ON MY
SIDE.
SO, IF WE CAN'T MAKE A DEAL
WITH CONGRESS, WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MAKE A DEAL WITH
CONGRESS.
IF YOU LOOK, DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS, ESPECIALLY THE NEW
ONES COMING IN ARE STARTING
TO SAY WAIT A MINUTE, WE
CAN'T WIN THIS BATTLE WITH
TRUMP BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT IT'S JUST COMMON SENSE.
HOW CAN WE SAY THAT A WALL
DOESN'T WORK?
THEY SHOW ON HELICOPTERS
EMPTY FIELDS AND PEOPLE JUST
RUNNING THROUGH.
AND YOU PUT A WALL, THEY
CAN'T RUN THROUGH.
>> Sean: WHAT ARE THE
OPTIONS THOUGH IF YOU
DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, THE PENTAGON ALSO
HAS THE FUNDS AVAILABLE THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP
SUPPORT THE BUILDING OF THE
WALL.
>> IF WE DON'T MAKE A DEAL
WITH CONGRESS, WHICH WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO.
REALLY JUST COMMON SENSE AND
THERE IS SOME COMPROMISE
NEEDED AND, LOOK, THEY KNOW
THAT THE WALL IS WORKING.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WORKS?
A WHEEL.
AND A WALL.
THEY CALL IT A MID EVIL
THING.
WELL, YOU KNOW, I'M LOOKING
AT ALL THESE VERY EXPENSIVE
CARS ALL OVER HERE LOADED UP
WITH MACHINE GUNS AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM HAS
WHEELS.
A WHEEL IS AN OLD THING.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT
WORK.
THEY WORK.
A WALL WOULD BE SO
EFFECTIVE.
IT WOULD SOLVE SO MANY
KILLINGS AND SO MUCH DEATH
AND DRUGS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
WHERE THEY TAPE UP WOMEN ON
THEIR FACE.
THEY TAPE THEM UP AND PUT
THEM IN THE BACK OF A CAR OR
A VAN AND THEY DRIVE RIGHT
THROUGH OUR BORDER.
>> Sean: I GUESS THE NEXT
MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION IS
WHEN YOU DO THAT, WOULD YOU
EXPECT THEY ARE GOING TO GO
JUDGE SHOPPING.
THEY WILL GO TO THE NINTH
CIRCUIT AND GO TO CALIFORNIA
TO START THE PROCESS.
IS THERE -- ARE YOUR
ATTORNEYS TELLING THREW IS
AN EXPEDITED WAY, PERHAPS TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
>> THEY ARE SAYING THERE
POSSIBLY IS AND HOPEFULLY WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
IT THE WALL IS VERY CLEAR.
WE HAVE THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT
TO DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AND THIS IS
SECURITY STUFF.
THIS IS A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HANG.
AND YOU JUST HEARD THE
STATEMENT THEY CAME IN LAST
WEEK OR THIS WEEK FROM
PAKISTAN AND DIFFERENT
PEOPLE.
THEY GOT THEM.
>> Sean: DID YOU SEE SARA
CARTER LAST KNIGHT HAD
PEOPLE FROM BANGLADESH.
>> THEY COME IN THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER BECAUSE IT'S
CONSIDERED THE SPACE AND
PLACE WHERE THEY CAN GET IN.
WE WANT TO CLOSE IT UP.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE DONE THE
GREATEST JOB.
IT'S HARD WORK.
AND IT COULD BE A LOT EASIER
AND IT WOULD BE VIRTUALLY
100 PERCENT EFFECTIVE.
AND NANNIES AND CHUCK KNOW
THAT, BUT IT'S POLITICS.
IT'S ABOUT THE 2020
CAMPAIGN.
IT'S ABOUT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THEY ARE ALREADY DOING IT.
IT'S A SHAME.
GOT TO PUT THE COUNTRY
FIRST.
FINALLY.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU SEE THE
SAME DEMOCRATS, HILLARY,
OBAMA, BIDEN, SCHUMER, ALL
SUPPORTING THIS, YOU KNOW,
IN 2006, 2013.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: THEY ARE NOT
SUPPORTING IT NOW.
IS IT BECAUSE YOU ARE THE
PRESIDENT AND THEY DON'T
WANT YOU TO GET A WIN?
SHOULDN'T THE WIN BE ABOUT
THE COUNTRY BEING SAFER,
MORE SECURE?
>> THEY KNOW WHAT I'M SAY
SOMETHING 100 PERCENT RIGHT.
IT'S NOT ONLY US, IT'S
EVERYBODY SAYING IT
EVERYBODY SAYS IT.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A BARRIER,
WHETHER IT'S A STEEL BARRIER
OR A CONCRETE WALL,
SUBSTANTIAL AND STRONG, YOU
NEVER ARE GOING TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM.
YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO SOLVE
IT.
AND I DON'T NEED.
THIS LOOK, I COULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING A LOT EASIER.
I COULD HAVE ENJOYED MYSELF.
I HAVEN'T LEFT THE WHITE
HOUSE BECAUSE I'M WAITING
FOR THEM TO COME OVER IN A
LONG TIME.
YOU KNOW THAT.
I STAYED HOME FOR CHRISTMAS.
I STAYED AT THE WHITE HOUSE
FOR NEW YEAR'S.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU TWEETED
CHRISTMAS EVE ALL ALONE,
WHERE IS CHUCK AND NANNIES.
>> MY FAMILY, I TOLD THEM
STAY IN FLORIDA AND ENJOY
YOURSELVES.
THE FACT IS I WANT TO BE IN
WASHINGTON.
I MEAN, I CONSIDER IT VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
TIME LINE BEFORE YOU THINK
YOU HAVE TO GO THE ROUTE AND
DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
>> WELL, I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
OVER THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
THEY SHOULD DO IT
IMMEDIATELY.
LOOK, WE'RE NOT GOING
ANYWHERE.
WE ARE NOT CHANGING OUR MIND
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING TO
CHANGE YOUR MIND ABOUT.
THE WALL WORKS.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION LIKE
MAYBE IT WON'T WORK.
IT WILL WORK 100 PERCENT.
WE ARE ADDING ON TO THAT
EQUIPMENT TO FIND DRUGS THAT
ARE HIDDEN IN CARS.
I MEAN, INCREDIBLE
EQUIPMENT.
WE ARE ADDING SENSORS AND
DRONES.
WHAT WE NEED IS WE NEED THE
BARRIER.
IF WE DON'T HAVE A BARRIER,
IF WE DON'T HAVE A STEEL OR
CONCRETE BARRIER, WE'RE ALL
WASTING A LOT OF TIME.
>> Sean: AND LIVES WILL BE
SAVED.
I KNOW YOU ARE THINKING
ABOUT THE FURLOUGHED
EMPLOYEES.
YOU SUPPORT THEM GETTING ALL
THEIR BACK PAY.
>> 100 PERCENT I SUPPORT
THEM TREMENDOUSLY.
BUT I ALSO SUPPORT FAMILIES
LIKE THE SINGH FAMILY AND
OTHERS.
OTHERS BY THE HUNDREDS AND
BY THE THOUSANDS THAT HAVE
LOST SOMEBODY BECAUSE OUR
POLICIES ARE SO BAD AND
ESPECIALLY AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THEY HAVE LOST AND THEY HAVE
HAD PEOPLE SO BADLY HURT.
BUT THEY HAVE LOST THEM.
THEY HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES.
THEY HAVE LOST THEIR HEART
OUT OF THE FAMILY.
I SUPPORT THOSE FAMILIES.
THE ANGEL MOMS, YOU KNOW THE
ANGEL MOMS VERY WELL.
>> Sean: I HAVE INTERVIEWED
THEM.
>> I SUPPORT THEM TOO.
>> Sean: DOES IT MEAN A LOT
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS DOWN
HERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY, IT DOES.
>> Sean: IS HE DESCRIBING
THE SITUATION ACCURATELY.
>> YES, SIR.
>> Sean: IF YOU GET THE WALL
THE DRUG ALSO STOP.
YOU CAN STOP THE CARTELS,
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, DRUG
TRAFFICKING THE GANGS.
>> YES.
>> Sean: IT WILL HELP.
>> IT WILL IMPROVE
EFFECTIVENESS.
>> Sean: BY WHAT PERCENT.
>> LIKE THE CHIEF SAID THE
MAJORITY OF OUR TRAFFIC IS
USUALLY COMING THROUGH AREAS